es otra mañana más en la que estos tres
hombres llegan hasta esta población
cercana bacmut para Elevar sus drones
las fuerzas rusas se encuentran a menos
de dos kilómetros y piden ocultar su
ubicación
solo una semana atrás no atacaban con
esa cantidad de artillería probablemente
los rusos han traído más munición y más
unidades de artillería
en cuestión de minutos instalan su
equipo en los últimos días los rusos han
acelerados ofensiva con trabajo la
tienen cercada por tres frentes y buscan
encerrar a la población y a las tropas
tal como lo hicieron con la ciudad de
Mario Paul
esta población donde estamos es
especialmente importante para ellos
porque es estratégica en su objetivo de
acercar a bamud por esa razón los
estamos sosteniendo
estos drones son los ojos del resto de
los hombres que defienden las posiciones
pero operarlos tiene grandes riesgos
sus operadores son objetivo de las
fuerzas rusas que saben que sin estos
aviones no tripulados los ucranianos
están ciegos
pasa la tensión y por fin logra levantar
el suyo
en la pantalla se ve como un caserío es
atacado allí vive el enemigo dice
literalmente ayer hubo muchos rusos aquí
los expulsamos a todos y no queda
ninguno al menos en este momento ellos
corren por los campos y se esconden en
los surcos de la vía especialmente en la
noche
cada vez más arrasada solo el centro de
la ciudad está bajo control ucraniano
pero su cámara no tiene la precisión
suficiente para apoyar al ejército desde
esta posición para eso necesitan drones
militares que piden a los países aliados
los drones civiles en algunas ocasiones
pierden señal y el control y eso hace
que los derrumben porque este equipo
está hecho para trabajar en las
condiciones donde todo funciona bien el
sistema alerta que se acaba la batería
es hora de desmontar
tienen que dirigirse a otra misión la
defensa de no para Aunque nadie Está
seguro Cuántos ataques más puedan
aguantar